uh was it tough to get the green light  on this thing there was no real pitching  process for this so I didn't go to  Studios and sort of say hey this is my  idea for a film it's about there's kids  and growing up in World War II it was um  I realized really early on that it's a  very hard film to pitch and I'm coming  from New Zealand we're terrible at  pitching So after talking to my friends  and saying and they said what are you up  to now and what are you running like  well I'm doing this thing it's about  this kid in World War II and there were  I'm not interested it's a that kind of  that made me realize oh no one really  wants to hear a pitch like this so I'm  going to write a script that's that's  really good and I'm going to let that be  the pitch so I wrote the screenplay and  I just sent that around I said I'm not  going to come talk to you about it you  just read the script and if you like it  then we can talk